-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
We hope you're doing well
and now, if you don't mind,
we're going to get to the news.
Amid tensions over possible
military action in Ukraine,
President Biden will meet
on a video call tomorrow
with Russian
President Vladimir Putin
because there's
no better deterrent
than a long video call
with a 79-year-old man.
[ Laughter ]
[ As Putin ]
You know, what?
This is not worth it.
[ Laughter ]
CNN announced over the weekend
that it has terminated
host Chris Cuomo
and, if you're wondering
what you have to do
to get fired from CNN,
Jeffrey Toobin
still works there.
[ Laughter and applause ]
And, if you don't know it, uh,
don't Google it.
[ Laughter ]
The Biden administration
announced today
that the U.S. will stage
a diplomatic boycott
of the 2022 Beijing Olympics
and, in retaliation,
China announced
that the iPhone 14
is going to look like this.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Arizona Senator Kyrsten Sinema
announced,
in an Instagram Story
over the weekend,
that she had
officially qualified
for the upcoming
Boston marathon.
But, fair warning
to the other runners --
she loves holding things up
at the finish line.
[ Laughter and applause ]
In a recent interview,
actor George Clooney said
that he turned down $35 million
to appear
in an airline commercial
because the carrier
was associated
with a country that does not
have a good human rights record.
Is it American?
[ Laughter and applause ]
New York Mayor Bill de Blasio
announced today
that all private employers
in the city
will soon be required
to mandate coronavirus
vaccinations for workers.
Otherwise, it's back to remote
work for Times Square Elmo.
[ Laughter and applause ]
I don't think Times Square Elmo
has a plant in his office.
[ Laughter ]
I don't think that's real,
Shoemaker.
[ Laughter ]
The New York Times
published a report yesterday
detailing a series
of coronavirus infections
stemming
from an animé convention
held last month in New York.
Well, something tells me
they'll be fine
with quarantining.
"Oh, you want me to stay
inside for 10 days?
Not a problem."
[ Laughter ]
According to the latest numbers,
the average cost per day
for a rental car
during the holiday season
is up by 75%, compared to 2019.
Even worse, they consider this
a Chevy Malibu, or similar.
[ Laughter ]
And, finally, a man in Italy
reportedly wore
a fake silicone arm last week
to avoid getting
the coronavirus vaccine.
And wait 'til you hear how he
got out of his vasectomy.
[ Laughter ]
[ Italian accent ]
Mamma mia!
[ Laughter and applause ]
That was a monologue, everybody!
[ Cheering and applause ]
Oh, man.